so the nobel prize for literature has
just been awarded to a tanzanian-born
novelist
guerner's work focuses on colonialism
and the fate of refugees he arrived in
the uk
as a refugee age 18 in the 1960s
and has now retired from teaching
english at the university of kent let's
go to paul reese who's now
in stockholm so paul how much of a
landmark is this year's prize
i think very much a landmark nick
especially for african literature
obviously for abdul razak gurner i'm
trying not to be impolite because the uh
press conference is still going on uh
behind me uh guerner the recipient of
this prize after
a process that's seen countless
nominations coming from around the world
sifted down to a list of five by the
nobel committee a secret list of five
we'll never know we will know in 50
years who the other nominees were and
then the chairman of the nobel committee
coming through the doors behind me and
making the rather solemn announcement
about
10 minutes ago but this is is
significant for
for one reason a few years ago the
swedish academy nearly 250 years old
institution
promised to modernize especially in the
wake of a me too scandal here in
stockholm involving the academy promised
to be more gender balanced promised to
be more global and
they have fulfilled that letter now this
is the first prize to a non-european or
american
in nearly a decade
but perhaps one stark statistic still is
that only 16 women have won this prize
still out of the 118
winners overall so 102 men to 16 women
um but still with abdul razak gerner's
prize cited for uh his writings on the
effect of colonialism um
giving a voice to refugees this is
obviously a wonderful day for african
literature
all right paul thanks very much uh
maurice in stockholm